Welcome to problem set five. Let's talk a bit about approximating vertex cover.
Suppose someone comes up to you and tells you that they devised
a really really clever algorithm for approximating vertex cover.
Let's call it clevervc.
Now, this is so clever that they don't actually want to show you the source code.
They want to keep it secret so you can't see that,
and they don't even return the list of vertices that are in the cover.
They just tell you the size of the cover.
So, how would you go about figuring out the performance of this and how it works?
In order to test the performance of clevervc,
how about we test it against four fairly large graphs
of 10,000; 20,000; 30,000; and 40,000 vertices,
and let's compare that against factor-2 approximation algorithm that we have.
See what the sizes that both come up with are.
So, you can see that the sizes of minimum vertex cover for clevervc
is always smaller than factor-2 approximation, sometimes, not very much.
For example in this run, 233 versus 234, not much of a difference.
In other cases, it's a rather large difference like 295 versus 600 in the 30,000 verticy graph.
Now, based on this table, there are number of things that we can say about clever-vc.
And these are the questions that I would like you to answer for me,
the statements that we can definitely say about clevervc,
and if you need to refer back to the table,
then we'll have that below in the instruction comments.
Can we say that given any graph, clevervc will outperform the 2-approximation algorithm
since in the graph that we gave it, it most certainly did outperform the 2-approximation algorithm?
Now, can we also say that clevervc is a factor-1.75 approximation algorithm
or finally could we actually say that clever-vc is not a correct algorithm?
And check true or false for all three of these.